[Música]
en primera plana
carlos bienvenidos a la primera plana un
programa de radio francia internacional
y de france 24 esta semana ponemos el
foco en los cursos limpios de tokio las
olimpiadas de la pandemia que están a la
vuelta de la esquina contamos en este
estudio con tres periodistas del mundo
deportivo alejandro valente es nuestro
jefe de deportes de recibió ha venido
alejandro muchas gracias carlos
bienvenidos a que ustedes sin ni
colmenares comentarista deportiva de la
radio rtl bienvenida sin din gracias
carlos bueno a todos y juan palacios
periodista independiente bienvenido juan
carlos buenos días un placer juegos
olímpicos de tokio las olimpiadas de la
pandemia hoy en primera plana
bueno pues con un año de retraso y en
circunstancias muy atípicas así serán
los juegos olímpicos de tokio 2020
aunque se celebran en pleno 2021 los
mejores atletas del mundo competirán en
la piscina en la pista alrededor del
velódromo y desde lo alto del trampolín
sin embargo los 3 kobin el equipo médico
las cuarentenas y la decisión aplazada
de la presencia de espectadores marcarán
esta cita tanto más que el propio
deporte y todo en un ambiente explosivo
cuando sanitarios y opinión pública de
japoneses no están por la labor de la
celebración cancelarlo ya lo dijeron los
organizadores es impensable y las
pérdidas serían cuantiosas toque 2020
parece haberse convertido en una
encrucijada que veremos qué tal sale
repasemos algunas portadas que nos deja
la prensa antes de la cita the japan
times
tokio 2020 de los atletas nuevas
orientaciones para su estancia la
organización sigue barajando la opción
de que no haya espectadores aquí en
francia diario libération
tokio ko los juegos a dos meses crecen
las incógnitas con una cuarta ola de
kobe azotando japón diario le parisien a
100 días de los juegos olímpicos
tokio se prepara
sea todo dice el rotativo que mientras
la opinión pública japonesa se muestra
hostil
el coi intenta tranquilizar con un
estilo con un estricto protocolo
sanitario bueno alejandro la presión
aumenta sobre el gobierno japonés lo
vimos lo hemos visto esta misma semana
nos es hacerte la pregunta pero ya no
hay marcha atrás verdad cuesta imaginar
que haya marcha atrás porque los juegos
olímpicos' por ahí uno no se da cuenta
cuando no está dentro de este mundo pero
los juegos olímpicos es una maquinaria
inmensa que mueve sumas muy importantes
ya sólo pensemos en las televisiones que
han pagado sumas considerables para
asegurar la difusión de estos juegos qué
pasa si no se celebran quién paga la
factura de todos los gastos
considerables que se han hecho para
organizar esto sin esto sin tener en
cuenta a los propios atletas que que
tienen esta cita cada cuatro años como
un momento clave en sus carreras
imaginar que no haya juegos en un
periodo de 8 años cuesta cuesta pensarlo
pero bueno es verdad que desde hace
tiempo los japoneses parecen muy
hostiles a la organización de estos
juegos
se ha visto incluso algunos sponsors en
tomar las distancias con estos juegos es
el caso de la empresa toyota que es
japonesa hemos visto algunos atletas
japoneses en particular en mostrarse
cada vez más reservados o sea que todo
todo parece todavía posible aunque las
autoridades japonesas siguen firmes en
su voluntad de organizar estos juegos lo
que parece que está claro es que toque
2020 serán los juegos más atípicos de la
historia no sé si os parece si japón y
tanto japón como el coi dan las
garantías suficientes podríamos decir
para la celebración es complicado
analizarlo porque es verdad que hay
sentimientos encontrados por un lado
muchas ganas de ver juegos olímpicos
porque bueno es como que el final del
túnel esperanza pero por otro lado no
podemos negar que las cifras del
ministerio de la salud en japón que
estamos a 1.214 personas que necesitan
asistencia respiratoria y bueno lo
personal de salud que están en primera
línea hay un descontento muy grande que
sigue creciendo de enfermeros de
sindicatos de enfermeros diciendo que se
debería dedicar estas sumas
la salud que es la principal la cosa
principal y al mismo tiempo es muy
difícil también para los atletas cuando
se escucha desde japón que es posible
que no haya prioridad para ellos de
camas en hospitales o sea cerveza
hostilidad que no debe ser muy fácil
para ellos de hecho algunos como eeuu
recientemente decidió no hacer los
entrenamientos allá sino seguimos
haciendo que eeuu antes de ir súper
complicado claro tenemos la parte
sanitaria por un lado la parte política
pero claro con lo que decía alejandro la
maquinaria y sobre todo las televisiones
no juegan las televisiones aquí son un
elemento clave si hay una
calendarización por lo que se prevé y se
confirma que los juegos olímpicos se van
a tener que realizar los intereses que
genera esta esta industria la
expectativa por parte de los atletas y
también la presencia del público porque
va a ser con una afluencia local pero
más allá de eso
considero que la estructura no solamente
es para lanzar un mensaje al exterior
sino también para dar la seguridad de
que es realizable de que realizable
abrir una etapa post pandemia es decir
esto también sería un mensaje
internacional no lo que se puede mandar
con lo mismo que estamos viendo con la
eurocopa por ejemplo de fútbol se habla
mucho de ese mensaje que se da qué bueno
que ya estamos saliendo de esa situación
pero es verdad que si se anularán esos
juegos olímpicos que no creo serían
decenas de miles de millones de dólares
perdidos porque ya es suficientemente
difícil la situación que no hay
espectadores ya estos días están
celebrando ensayos y se ha aplazado la
visita del director del coi por la
extensión del estado de urgencia en
japón la decisión del público queda
aplazada junio sabemos solo que no habrá
turistas y que medidas como las
mascarillas serán obligatorias a partir
de ahí muchísimas incógnitas aún no
cuáles son las principales que nos
quedan porque ya sólo para los medios
que tenemos que cubrir estos juegos
nosotros inicialmente ene efe y había un
previsto enviar 16 personas a tokio
hemos revisado nuestros planes
y hemos bajado a 11 por el momento y
cada dos meses más o menos recibimos del
coi un documento que se llama el
playbook donde dan todas las consignas
que habrá que respetar y cada vez se
vuelve algo algo más complicado o sea
hay que pensar que por ejemplo un
periodista que vaya a tokio tiene que ya
quince días antes comenzar a tomar
medidas a tomar la temperatura
diariamente tiene que pasar dos test e
inmediatamente antes de viajar en
laboratorios identificados por las
autoridades japonesas otro test al
llegar tres días de cuarentena y luego
test cotidianos y el trabajo en el
estadio va a ser súper complicado el fin
todo se ha vuelto extremadamente difícil
y durante 14 días los periodistas o
técnicos o personas que viajen no podrán
ir a un restaurante no podrán tomar el
transporte público no podrán ir a
ninguna otra parte que no sea el estadio
'olímpico' o sea que son condiciones de
coberturas que nos alejan mucho de lo
que son naturalmente los juegos que es
una gran fiesta universal
donde la gente tiene el placer de
compartir de estar junta de mezclarse y
va a ser exactamente lo contrario aún
cuando se sale desde luego el espíritu
olímpico va a estar un poco atrás tocado
eso para los periodistas pero también en
la villa olímpica los deportistas
también van a vivir en una especie de
burbuja no bueno si son un test hace
poco y australianos atletas decían pero
es increíble porque llegamos que
estuvimos allí encerrados no pudimos ir
a conocer la ciudad a una ciudad tan
bella como tokio sa es increíble la
manera en la que van a estar de esa
manera encerrados por todas las
previsiones normalmente deberían ser los
juegos olímpicos de la igualdad
sostenible y finalmente tenemos la
impresión que son los juegos olímpicos
de la pandemia simplemente lo cual es
muy triste porque han ido a nada otros
avances respecto a estos juegos
olímpicos entonces bueno y pese a todo
les quiero plantear una cosa que no sea
un poco políticamente incorrecta y pese
a todo hablamos de japón es decir se
confía en un minucioso protocolo o se
confía que todas las infraestructuras
estén en sí hablaremos de otra ciudad en
estos juegos de pandemia sin querer
nombrar a ninguna pero todos en la mente
con muchas nos estaríamos en otras
constancia se ha medido social hubiesen
manifestaciones pro teóricas muy
importantes es verdad que la sociedad
japonesa es una sociedad que tiene
valores que se concretó en nuestra
organización en este protocolo y también
en el hecho de que cuando empiezan los
juegos olímpicos no se puede negar que
siempre habrá sea lo que sea entusiasmo
porque son espera atletas incluso si las
personas no va a poder estar adentro los
extranjeros siempre habrá la televisión
que va a difundir y la gente detrás de
sus atletas entonces las situaciones a
las cuales también tenemos que
acomodarnos no en un principio ustedes
han manifestado la villa olímpica no
solamente pasa por el aspecto deportivo
porque también es un centro de vida
social entre todos los atletas que
habitualmente comparten realizan una
serie de experiencias e incluso se
realizan fiestas dentro de la vida
olímpica y lo que va a ser también la
cobertura periodística no porque hay
restricciones básicamente
las cifras que se pagan para poder
realizar esta cobertura pero en
contraparte también
las restricciones que van a existir
teniendo en cuenta de que nosotros como
periodistas siempre queremos las
reacciones de los deportistas destacados
y de todo lo que se realiza y sobre todo
la información de primera mano pero si
hay ese tipo de restricción también es
algo que muestra lo atípico que van a
ser estos juegos olímpicos y en torno al
70 por ciento de los japoneses considera
que sería mejor volver a aplazar la
convocatoria o cancelar definitivamente
la cita olímpica claro para el gobierno
nipón también es un reto organizar todo
esto si algo sale mal con la opinión
pública en contra aplazar aplazar los
posibles productos si no se hacen se
anulan lisa y llanamente evidentemente
aquí en parís seguimos todo esto con
mucho interés porque los próximos juegos
de los picos son los de parís en 2024 y
habrá un periodo más breve entre los dos
juegos puesto que hemos pasado de 4 a 3
años y evidentemente la manera en que
estos juegos se van a llevar a cabo van
a influir en la manera en que parís lo
va a ser ya sean
ha tomado medidas para reducir los
costos para reducir cierto número de
competiciones que van a tener lugar aquí
en parís y evidentemente la manera en
que esto se lleve a cabo en tokio va a
tener una influencia considerable en la
próxima edición que tendrá lugar aquí de
toda la perspectiva también cronológica
biológica de un deportista no porque hay
una preparación donde uno tiene los
plazos fijos y ahora hay un retraso
obviamente en cuanto a las perfomances
en cuanto a las perspectivas que tiene
el deportista tampoco no es lo mismo
imagínense todos los cambios que esto
genera definitivamente del exterior no
muestra una incertidumbre pero también
creo que la voluntad del deseo del
deportista porque para muchos es la
última oportunidad que tienen de poder
lograr una buena performance de poder
hacer historia creo que eso también hace
que de alguna manera el espíritu
olímpico esté presente no porque
obviamente
el trabajo del deportista durante mucho
tiempo y sobre todo lo que es el momento
indicado para para poder realizar y para
poder ser protagonista hablamos de toda
esta situación de comida hasta el
momento en el que empiecen los juegos
una vez ya que empiecen los juegos nos
concentraremos ya en otras cosas que a
lo mejor ya es más el espíritu olímpico
y eso no aunque siempre serán atípicas
estas olimpiadas es complicado
económicamente porque ya aunque sólo sea
para acceder a los atletas ya las
consignas que recibimos son muy
complicadas en la zona mixta que es el
lugar donde se juntan los atletas con
los periodistas al final de una prueba
ya nos han informado que sólo podrá
haber un periodista cada equis instancia
tendrá que mantener dos metros de
distancia con el atleta la entrevista no
podrá superar 90 segundos
todo eso va a ser va a ser una situación
muy difícil porque para los atletas que
están con toda la excitación de la
competición tener que someterse a esa
distancia a ese contacto tan serio con
la prensa va a ser va a ser algo
forzosamente frustrante que están o sea
porque hay también el hecho de la vacuna
que es muy importante hay unos que van
de hecho
vacunado la mayoría en francia este tema
se trata de manera muy discreta puesto
que en francia tenemos límites como en
varios países para la vacuna a partir de
una edad precisa ahora van a abrir el 15
de junio para todos pero los atletas ya
se han vacunado en todo caso es lo que
desean vacunarse en alemania y hungría
hungría empezó en febrero o sea ese tipo
de temas también entran en cuenta y
saben cómo va a ser el espíritu olímpico
de estos juegos nos vamos a una pequeña
pausa ya vuelta vamos a hablar más de
deporte si podemos hasta ahora
[Música]
nuestros equipos recogen los testimonios
de los que viven la noticia una mirada
diferente a la actualidad
vídeos que no verá en ningún otro sitio
los observadores en france 24 y france
24 puntocom
[Música]
france24 punto com está disponible en
cuatro idiomas artículos reportajes
noticias internacionales continuamente
todas nuestras ediciones para ver de
nuevo y el canal en directo 24 horas los
7 días intuitivo rápido y en cuatro
lenguas france24 puntocom liberté
égalité actual y t
seguimos aquí en primera plana esta
semana ponemos poniendo el foco en los
juegos olímpicos de la pandemia en tokio
2020 pero que se celebra en 2021
aplazado un año y que ya no se va
aplazar más lo hacemos con alejandro
valente jefe de deportes de ref y los
periodistas deportivos síndico almenares
y juan palacios estos juegos olímpicos
serán pioneros en un tema social muy de
actualidad la paridad por primera vez en
la cita olímpica habrá al menos un
hombre y una mujer en todos y cada uno
de los comités olímpicos nacionales
participantes un total de 206 equipos
que contarán con al menos una atleta
femenina en sus filas y que además
podrán presentar dos abanderados según
datos proporcionados por el comité
olímpico internacional el 49 por ciento
de los participantes en la cita olímpica
son mujeres estamos ante los primeros
juegos olímpicos con un equilibrio de
género real en la historia sí en todo
caso hemos avanzado los primeros
normalmente serán los de parís 2024 y no
esté por azar es que en realidad parís
en 1900 fueron los primeros donde hubo
mujeres y tiene mucha historia entonces
va a ser un signo fuerte pero si es
verdad que vamos a 48,8 por ciento de
paridad de igualdad y es muy importante
y han habido ya decisiones también muy
fuertes bueno se vio respecto al
presidente de enapu que tuvo que ser
cambiado por la que es actual así moto
por los comentarios que pudo hacer
respecto a los juegos olímpicos ya las
mujeres que hablan mucho más que ese
tipo de cosas y poco a poco han habido
es verdad que la sensibilidad de estos
casos ya no es la del pasado es decir
claro hay un escándalo pero porque ya
hay una repercusión pública de este tipo
de manifestaciones es decir si es eso
las mentalidades han avanzado mucho y es
eso lo que ha hecho poco a poco y
también todos los esfuerzos que se han
hecho porque han sido años de esfuerzos
de mujeres que participan que han ganado
como charlotte cooper que fue la primera
tengan que ganó en los olímpicos o sea
es todo esos esfuerzos que han llevado a
que poco a poco
logre en esta igualdad finalmente pero
el género también está principalmente el
rendimiento de deportistas de alta
competencia o sea no básicamente por
buscar un equilibrio es que de repente
vamos a tomar en cuenta de por qué se
realizan de esta manera los juegos
olímpicos sino el rendimiento porque es
verdad hay muchas atletas del género
femenino que prometen por su performance
por por su rendimiento porque crean
bastante expectativa y eso determina
también la tendencia de los juegos
américa latina' fijémonos en la región
porque incrementa la cifra de
participantes en tokio 2020 al menos 10
países de la región suman 500 79 atletas
clasificados entre 24 deportes alejandro
que esperanzas cabe reseñar para el
medallero de la región bueno digamos que
américa latina con algunas excepciones
notables como puede ser el caso de cuba
que a menudo fue un país líder en la
región este año menos con menos
representaciones disminuyendo en 48
y con la aparición de figuras de figuras
o de disciplinas en las que algunos
países latinoamericanos suelen brillar
pienso por ejemplo en el caso de
argentina con el hockey femenino o bien
con disciplinas colectivas que a menudo
se dan bien a los países
latinoamericanos no se trata de los
países que están mejor mejor expuestos
ni mejor representados pero bueno eso
sabemos en francés pero bueno siempre
siempre es un momento importante porque
permite comparar y permite fijar pautas
que van a que van a hacer avanzar las
cosas y pienso que en el tema de la
paridad de américa latina es un
continente que también avanza el que
boca vamos antes y también la aparición
de nuevas de nuevos conceptos que me
parece interesante reseñar porque más
allá de la paridad están las
competiciones mixtas que se están
desarrollando hasta ahora pocas eran las
disciplinas donde había hombres y
mujeres que competían al mismo tiempo
hoy en día todo eso se está
generalizando y puede dar también o
permitir que haya países que se
destaquen en ese terreno hay
oportunidades que se crean muy bien
ya hay disciplinas en las que algunos
países brillan más que otros sin que se
sepa muy bien por qué puede haber en
este tema de la amistad también
oportunidades para américa latina la cnn
ha hecho una proyección del medallero
les cuento eeuu es una proyección
todavía eeuu 114 seguido de chino 85 y
los deportistas de la federación rusa
que ahora ahora si queréis hablar de
esto que hay que llamarlo así en tercer
lugar el anfitrión llegaría cuarto y
francia sexta más o menos creíble más o
menos allí hay una tendencia de
realmente por el tema basada en los
últimos rendimientos pero eso
definitivamente no sé si hay una
certitud en un porcentaje altísimo de un
90 a 80 por ciento porque tengamos en
cuenta que en las ediciones anteriores
de juegos olímpicos por ejemplo
argentina le ganó en basquetbol a los
eeuu que sería inimaginable
hay algunos atletas de repente que que
aprovechan de un concurso de
circunstancias también y de inspiración
más allá de las cualidades
y calidad que ellos tengan para lograr
una marca importante en su momento y
acceder a una medalla o sea son cifras
especulativas pero de repente no sé si
realmente se puedan acercar a una
realidad porque siempre este hay algunas
sorpresas también más allá de que es
verdad las perfomances de los de los
atletas es generalmente conocida y ahora
vayamos otra cosa también el sistema de
clasificación no porque en algunas diez
disciplinas no se han hecho como
habitualmente los juegos preolímpicos es
por eso que esto también marca un enigma
no de lo que puede ser y si realmente
esa cifra es cercana increíble y muy
difícil hacer estadísticas cuando faltan
tantas competencias que ciudadanos se
desplazaron no pudieron hacerse entonces
ellos mismos cuando comunican dicen que
bueno son pronósticos pero que no
estamos muy seguros de eso yo de cartas
que no han podido entrenarse en
condiciones satisfactorias según los
países o las zonas continentales ha sido
muy difícil aquí en francia por ejemplo
la práctica del deporte se ha visto se
ha visto muy alterada durante los
periodos
de pandero y todo esto sin hablar de los
juegos paralímpicos que también van a
celebrarse y cuyos participantes sufren
aún más las consecuencias de la pandemia
vamos a lanzar con muchos temas que nos
quedan rusia después de que en los
juegos olímpicos de invierno de
sochi-2014 surgió la evidencia del
dopaje respaldado por el estado en
diciembre de 2019 rusia fue vetada del
deporte internacional durante cuatro
años aunque esta prohibición luego fue
reducida a la mitad en qué condiciones
participa rusia vamos a explicarlo muy
difícil porque bueno ellos no tienen o
no participan como anuncia primero no
tienen derecho al himno nacional ni a
los colores incluso si bueno los colores
blanco azul y rojo estarán en su
vestimenta pero bueno y de hecho
trataron de poner una canción que aún
cuando no fuese el himno es una canción
que se usaba para marchas patriótica
militar y al final le anularon y otra
otra canción que es muy importante
también para ellos pero bueno es muy
difícil también siendo atletas que van
de manera
correcta a esos juegos de llevar esa
carga de lo que hicieron otros atletas y
de hecho un sistema porque
lamentablemente en rusia se demostró que
sistémica en este tipo de cosas que
suceden de dopaje entonces difícil ese
peso
es un tema muy complejo no el tema del
doping en el que en el sentido de que si
nos fijamos un poco en las ediciones
pasadas hay un precedente de que hay
muchas atletas que han conseguido
medallas y lamentablemente tiempo
después se ha descubierto de que habían
consumido alguna sustancia prohibida
que no se tome a mal pero los países de
europa del este
muchas veces se ha hablado sobre estos
temas sobre todo por la performance de
los atletas que llegan desde desde ese
punto no el por qué porque hay muchas
maneras para contrarrestar si bien el
comité olímpico internacional señala una
lista no de elementos prohibidos pero
hay formas de contrarrestar eso no
con las transfusiones de sangre hay
distintos elementos por los cuales de
repente han sacado ventaja y se ha
sabido después o sea yo creo que el
doping ha habido y siempre habrá no en
la alta competencia
eso es eso no cabe duda ahora como decía
escindir lo que sea castigado aquí es
sobre todo un sistema político que ha
llevado a aquel a imponer digamos eso
como una verdadera política deportiva y
evidentemente esto tenía que ser
sancionado de alguna manera siempre
puede ser frustrante evidentemente para
los atletas individualmente pero era
difícil no hacerlo a pesar de que el coi
trató de limitar el impacto de las
consecuencias van a ser importantes
novedades deportivas el béisbol y el
sóftbol regresan después de una ausencia
de 13 años y luego están los nuevos los
nuevos deportes karate surf escalada
deportiva
y skateboarding no sé si me querés
comentar algo de surf en japón pero es
que están unos cuantos kilómetros no la
playa el béisbol y el sóftbol son son
disciplinas masivas en japón
obviamente que consecuente a la
organización y sobre todo por los
tiempos que están pasando creo que es
importantísimo también valorar ese tipo
de deportes porque se dan las
condiciones porque es el lugar preciso y
de alguna manera para algunos nos
sorprenden o tal vez la presión
que quitar o puede añadir alguna
disciplina como se hace muchísimas
razones pero tiene que ver bueno con la
popularidad de la visibilidad el
marketing también tiene que ver con
cosas como la técnica es que un deporte
que tiene en verdad técnica y el
desarrollo tiene visiones de desarrollo
ese deporte por ejemplo en parís en el
2024 va a ver el breakdance pero en
verdad parece no cumplir con todas estas
condiciones pero al mismo tiempo es un
deporte que también habla a la juventud
y ese es el tipo de cosas que también
quieren promover de hablar
a los jóvenes y hacer un poco de vos
respecto a eso es tan importante la
universalidad de un deporte y fue eso lo
que penalizó al béisbol y el sóftbol que
son deportes que si bien son muy
populares en algunos países no están
quizás suficientemente practicados a
nivel universal y eso también es un
hándicap para algunas disciplinas el
carácter que citaba se va a hacer su
aparición en tokio pero luego no estará
en parís serán emplazados justamente por
el breakdance y luego las grandes
ausencias las grandes ausencias que han
marcado citas olímpicas anteriores los
grandes nombres como pues usain bolt o
michael fed sobre todo a este nivel
estratosférico quien les va a reemplazar
en esta fila
no aparece no pero habrán otros y habrán
de otra manera pero en el imposible en
todo caso a corto plazo es el carisma no
es tanto obviamente las capacidades de
otros tienen capacidades y también muy
grandes pero el carisma que tienen o que
saben desarrollar estos jugadores creo
que es tan difícil reemplazar los
artistas que van a
marcar el inicio a esa celebridad no
solamente por una cuestión de
performance sino también por popularidad
porque hoy los atletas son mucho más
mediáticos lo cual atrae también a los a
los sponsors es algo importantísimo y la
aceptación que tienen entre la gente y
el interés que generan en el aficionado
general o sea esto va a marcar el inicio
de muchos atletas que van a marcar la
historia y quedó sin tiempo ya si me
queréis decir un nombre podéis pero ya
simplemente nombre nombre porque bueno
por ejemplo mbappe sueña con venir a
jugar con francia
muchísimas gracias a los tres me quedo
sin tiempo sin más muchas gracias por
habernos contó cómo serán estas
olimpiadas de la pandemia de tokio 2020
que se celebran en 2021 y a todos
ustedes hasta la próxima semana quien en
primera plana gracias